[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis le poinur des
lil le gars qu'on croise et qu'on ne
regarde pas il y a pas de soleil sous la
terre drôle de croisière pour tuer
l'ennui j'ai dans ma veste les
extraits et dans qu il a écrit je
dégasse la coule douce à
Miami pendant ce temps que je fais le
soive profond de la cave paraît qu'il y
a pas de son métier moi je fais les
trous dans les billets je fais les trous
des petits trous encore des petits trous
des petits trous des petits trous
toujours des petits trous des trous de
seconde
classe des trous de première class je
fais des trous les petits trous encore
les petits trous les petits trous les
petits trous toujours les petits trous
petits trous les petits
trous un coinur des lil AR métier direct
par le
valoir j'en ai marre j'en ai ma claque
de ce claque je voudrais jouer la fille
de l'air laisser ma cascade horestière
un jour viendra j'en suis
sûr je pourrais m'évader dans la
nature je partirai sur la prend en route
coute que cûe et si pour moi il n'est
plus temps je partirai les pieds devant
je fais les trous les petits trous
encore les petits trous les petits trous
les petits trous toujours les petits
trous il y a de quoi devenir
dingue de quoi prendre un
flingue se faire un trou un petit trou
un dernier petit trou un petit trou un
petit trou un dernier petit trou et on
me met trit dans un grand trou et je
n'entendrai plus parler de trou plus
Jama m de trous de petit trou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]